what does it look like in your brain
when you're playing a game are you
seeing all the possibilities and I mean
just describe it what what is what do
you see when you look when you look at a
board uh when a computer looks at a at a
position it will consider all the
possibilities it will see all the
different possibilities and it will
calculate them many many moves ahead uh
for me it's more about seeing the right
possibilities finding the right ideas
and evaluating them correctly and if I
need to I will uh be able to calculate
the uh the moves uh many many moves
ahead uh but it's really more
about um uh finding uh finding the right
ones and then the board is always
pictured in my head uh there's an image
of uh of the board moving moving the
pieces around